we all make poor life choices take these
two guys for example they're the
founders of a self-driving car company
called Zeus and they've decided it makes
sense to try and compete against this
way mode the Google self-driving car
project ruse automation Daimler by the
uber and lyft
zooks is different its rivals are adding
self-driving technology to existing car
meanwhile tzuke's is making a new type
of vehicle for the self-driving aide
[Music]
basically Zuke's is making a robot and
its early incarnation looks like the
lovechild of the matrix Mad Max and
transformers franchises
this is Tim kentley clay he hails from
Australia and Down Under he was a well
known designer an ADD guy one day he had
an epiphany a vision of the future full
of robotic vehicles and came here to
build I started to soul a future of how
the whole system could work said okay I
need to find a brilliant computer
scientist and so that led me on a
journey for six months actually we ended
up finding Jesse that brilliant computer
scientist is dr. Jesse Levinson a
Stanford grad who was sought after by
none other than Google itself I actually
visited Google X in 2013 to come and
speak on my vision for autonomy it's in
talking a fella this is one guy he's
really good and we can't get him that
was my signal to go and get him a lot of
your colleagues and run off to companies
like Google or
Obert retrofitted cars what drew you to
this particular task and was approached
I've been working on self-driving cars
since 2005 and it's pretty clear even
back then that there was gonna be one of
the more transformative technologies for
a society it wasn't enough to just solve
a technology you need a product and you
need a business that makes sense
and I hadn't seen that in any other
company and until I met Tim and he
shared his high level of vision for what
suits could be and that vision is a
system of completely autonomous robotic
vehicles that can be summoned just like
a lift or did I say it
Anouar we have a very clear vision of
tzuke's
which is that AI and mobility will take
us out of the age of the automobile and
into the next mobility age which Russ's
robotics autonomous transportation
[Music]
timming Jesse take me to the Alameda
Naval Air Station where I'm about to get
a test drive and see how is Duke's robot
handles these are very unique vehicles
they're designed in a way that would
only make sense if they're gonna be
fully autonomous the power trains are
designed for full autonomy they're fully
were done and they have dual high
voltage batteries they have dual
low-voltage architectures you can see
they're rigged would compute sensors
they can drive without any human
intervention this is the age for this is
the age five you want to go for a ride
yeah I do all right jump in
zooks is placed cones on the tarmac the
robot is gonna drive out and try to
dodge them and I get to do the whole
test sitting backwards because Tim I
thought it would be fun yeah keyboard
hold there I
maybe my robot mega and with one swift
keystroke
I give complete control of my life over
to an AI
that really doesn't get old it's like we
had a ride at Disney these AI robots
cranked through the course at 45 miles
per hour and the vh 5 is set to rip
through it and a delightful 75 miles per
hour pick and choose all-wheel steering
2 wheel steering crab steering dual
motors and then we have direction
I like the crabs do zooks got its start
here in the sub and entire house back in
2015 with only 6 employees they've since
raised an astonishing 800 million
dollars and have expanded their
operations into a one-stop robot making
shop with the help of 400 employees Zeus
is now on their way to turning these
prototypes into full-fledged vehicles by
2020 for the moment though zooks does
most of its software testing in these
modified versions of Toyota Highlanders
which have the decided advantage of
being street-legal we're actually gonna
need to drive autonomously from this
facility to our new headquarters in
Foster City and then Jesse's gonna jump
in and you can drive all to downtown San
Francisco we don't know any company in
the world that is driving that
multi-dimensional degree of difficulty
from urban to freeway to dense downtown
[Music]
so that's a that's a bicycle that was a
cyclist if that's a car behind us it's
something like the speed limit
does that get taken by the cameras
seeing the signs or that's something
that has to get answered in as you map
the world if there's a sign that's been
vandalized or it's missing or it's got
new growth on it the vehicle wouldn't
know what the speed limit is and that
could cause an incident or a fine
so speed limits are really well
understood on the road networks so we
put that in as a prior on the map okay
so coming up right here we have to do a
left turn yield yeah so we're concerned
about this car that's coming towards us
from prediction level so we just want to
make sure that they do the right thing
and now we're yielding if you look on
this screen see there's yellow here yeah
that means we're yielding for that
vehicle okay and now we're off we're
about to drive onto the freeway so this
will be interesting you can see there's
quite a bit of traffic on our left yeah
and the vehicle is indicating at the
moment it's going to brake a little bit
harder because we've got this vehicle
right on our six yeah
and we're running out of runway and now
we merge in
so that would've been a hard situation
even for a human driver we needed to
merge and that person the left was not
letting us in we tried to go in front
they stayed with us and then we had to
break let them go past and then we
pulled in yeah was that was all
autonomous and you can see how smooth
that was good robot some of the hardest
things to do a little Thomas driving is
actually prediction because you'd only
need to understand what's the state of
the world is you have to say well what's
the state of the world in the near
future if I do this what would that
person do and so that creates very
quickly a large search tree and the
vehicles going to drive with good
performance you need to be able to
predict well the state of the world in
the near future
yeah I'm new headquarters 20 minutes
suburban driving freeways merging 100%
autonomous yeah that was incredible
that's amazing all right guys let's go
two for two no pressure
what's like in each box it looks like
there's like a why and how yeah there's
a V an R and an L so V means vision R
means radar an L means lidar so we used
cameras use a radar and we use lidar
cameras are really good at seeing what
things our radar is really good at
seeing where things are in terms of how
far away they are
and then lidar is really good at telling
you where things are in 3d at pretty
high resolution and pretty high accuracy
and so what we do is we fuse those three
sensors together in real time to form
one coherent view of the world which is
actually what you're looking at on the
screen definitely crowded I mean that
must make it harder oh yeah yeah it's a
lot to keep track of we have made it at
honestly the San Francisco Francisco as
far as the public knows
zooks along with Wei MO and GM crews are
the only companies capable of doing this
kind of drive and this is the first time
they've ever shown the cars in action to
the public is it madness to take on many
of the world's leading automotive and
tech companies at the same time yes of
course it is but I say go forth Tim and
Jesse we all await our Luck's robotic
ride share of the future click on the
link to subscribe